Narrator: Take a look at
this shot from "The Shining."
A pretty innocent scene.
But when we zoom out,
the space suddenly becomes menacing.
That's partly because compositions
like this stress us out.
All that empty, or negative, space
tells us there's something lurking
and that this character is in danger.
Negative space is just one of many tools
horror-film makers use
to play on your senses
without you even noticing.
Let's take a look at
some of the hidden ways
horror movies manipulate
you into being scared.
You might have heard
about nonlinear sounds.
[shrill, suspenseful music]
[screams]
We are conditioned to respond
to those screeching strings with fear.
But the opposite of that
can be even more unsettling.
[growling]
[screaming]
Hear that low rumble?
[growling]
[screaming]
You might've felt it
more than you heard it.
That's because this scene uses
super-low-frequency sounds
that are right at the limit
of what humans can hear.
The human ear is best
at registering sounds
above the frequency of 20 hertz.
Anything below that is called infrasound.
Horror movies like "Paranormal Activity"
use sounds right around
that 20-hertz threshold,
called sub-bass sounds.
It's these deep rumblings
that ratchet up the
tension in key moments.
According to some studies,
we also often feel them,
experiencing the sound waves
in our bodies as vibration.
People subjected to
infrasound and sub-bass sounds
reported feelings of
discomfort, even chills,
or worse, like when director Gaspar Noé
used nonstop sub-bass sounds
through the first 30 minutes
of his movie "Irreversible."
[ambient tones rumbling]
[men speaking indistinctly]
The BBC reported that 20 people
at the Cannes Film Festival
fainted during the film
and needed medical attention.
These sounds operate at the outer edges
of your hearing range to
make you uncomfortable
without you even knowing why.
And this idea can apply to
your visual senses, too.
Did you catch that?
This white face is one
of several hidden shots
of the demon in "The Exorcist."
They are often referred
to as subliminal images,
which isn't really accurate,
since we are able to
consciously perceive them.
But each image only lasts
about an eighth of a second on screen,
less than a blink of an eye.
Research shows that people
presented with threatening
images, even briefly,
become faster at identifying
additional threats.
That state of hypervigilance
is right where horror movies want you.
So as each flash comes on screen,
you get better at catching them,
but you might also question
whether you saw anything at all.
And that's the point.
At the end of "Psycho,"
director Alfred Hitchcock
placed this image
of Mrs. Bates' skull
over Norman Bates' face,
but didn't include this detail
in all prints of the movie.
So in theaters, you
might've seen the skull
in one screening and not in the next.
The American remake of "The
Ring" played a similar trick
by inserting shots from
the cursed videotape
as flash frames in different
scenes of the movie,
but varying the frames in
different versions of the film.
These fleeting images and, more generally,
the popular horror-movie style
of quick-cutting between shots
work to disorient you
and make you question your own perception.
Casey: Hello?
Killer: Why don't you want to talk to me?
Narrator: See all this?
That's called negative
space: anything in the frame
that's not the subject we're focusing on.
Movies traditionally go
for a harmonious balance
of positive and negative space.
The subject is placed at
the rule-of-thirds lines,
and there's more space
in the direction the subject's facing,
allowing what's called lead room.
Horror movies deliberately
violate those rules
to make audiences squirm.
Sometimes they'll put the subject
almost on the edge of that frame line,
so the blank space overwhelms the frame,
or they'll leave more empty
space behind the subject,
which makes us wonder
if something's going to
sneak up on them.
Camera movements in horror movies
often emphasize the
negative space even more.
See the slow pans in these scenes?
Or in these scenes, how the
camera lingers on empty spots?
In horror movies, you'll sometimes see
the camera actually leave the subject
and track through a vacant room,
filling the shot with only negative space.
Leaving all this openness in the frame
lets the audience's
imagination fill in the blanks.
We're left wondering if or
when some attacker will pop up
and from which direction.
Extreme wide establishing
shots can also draw attention
to how alone and vulnerable
the protagonists are
and how remote the setting is.
How many times have you seen
shots like this in horror movies?
They work so well to set the scene
because they play on some
of our most primal fears
of isolation and defenselessness.
So if too much empty space freaks us out,
what happens when the shot
has almost no space at all?
It can actually amp up the fear even more,
especially in climactic scenes.
In this scene from "The Nun,"
we see a shot of Valak
rise up from the water,
then go to a close-up of the protagonist
looking on in horror.
By the time we cut to a wide shot again,
Valak's now fully out of the water,
towering over Irene.
This is a common pattern in horror movies.
They'll show you the monster
approaching or coming into view,
then cut to a tight close-up
of the protagonist reacting.
It's terrifying because we know
the monster's advancing or attacking,
but we're not allowed to see it happening.
We're only witnessing it secondhand
through the protagonist's response.
More generally, tight
shots on the protagonist
make it so you can't see what's going on,
like in this scene from "Psycho."
Notice the camera's tight
on Detective Arbogast
as he goes up the stairs,
so we can't see what danger
he might be walking into.
That leaves us feeling as
helpless and on edge as he is.
Another way of keeping
audiences in the dark
is by manipulating camera focus.
In this scene from "Donnie Darko,"
we go from a shot of Jake
Gyllenhaal from behind
to an out-of-focus medium
close-up of his face.
As he slowly walks into
focus, he becomes crisper,
but the background remains blurry,
leaving us wondering what
might be lurking there.
That shot uses shallow focus.
That's when the aperture of
a camera's lens is wide open,
creating a shallow depth of field.
This allows filmmakers to finely control
which people or objects
in the frame stay sharp.
In other genres, filmmakers
use shallow focus
to direct our attention to
the in-focus part of the shot.
But horror-film makers
weaponize shallow focus
to make us uncomfortable.
Let's look at another creepy
Jake Gyllenhaal scene,
this one from the movie "Enemy."
Here are the two subjects:
Mélanie Laurent, who's being followed,
and Jake, who's following her.
Both are equally important,
but one's in the sharp foreground,
and the other's in the blurry background.
This leaves us unsure
where to direct our eyes,
and it forces us as audience members
into an uncomfortable
and hyperattentive state.
Here's another key way horror
movies play with perspective.
Jill: Hi, it's Jill, the babysitter.
Narrator: This is a framing device
sometimes called the dark voyeur
or hidden onlooker perspective.
The camera might shoot
from behind something,
a bush or a piece of furniture,
or through something, like a window.
This perspective puts us
in the uncomfortable
position of being voyeurs,
where we know something that
the protagonist doesn't:
that they are being watched.
The shot can also separate the audience
from the actual scene.
Here, for example, we're
looking on from another room.
That framing makes us
hyperaware of our powerlessness
to stop what's about to happen.
We can only watch, complicit,
which can make for a pretty
torturous viewing experience.
If the dark voyeur perspective
turns the audience into observers,
the first-person-killer perspective
turns us into accomplices.
That's the classic slasher "Halloween,"
opening with a shot from the
murderer's point of view.
The first-person-killer perspective
is a hallmark of slasher movies,
popularized by the earliest
films in that genre.
The first-person-victim perspective
can be just as powerful,
because it literally puts
us in the character's shoes
as they approach danger.
That's why many horror
movies use a shaky cam.
Friend: Jason, what are you doing?
Narrator: Or a zooming effect
like the kind in "Vertigo,"
which makes us feel as dizzy and uneasy
as the protagonist does in the scene.
Both types of first-person-POV shots
are effective for a few reasons.
For one, they hide crucial
information about the scene.
In the second half of
"The Blair Witch Project,"
the more danger the protagonists are in,
the lower and more shakily
they hold the camera,
never focusing the lens
on anything for very long.
In the opening shot of "Halloween,"
Michael Myers' mask is
partially covering the camera,
so we're not privy to
everything in the frame.
Even more importantly,
we don't know the identity
of this unseen intruder.
That's also why Steven Spielberg
used the first-person-POV shots in "Jaws":
to hide the shark from the audience,
which famously worked to make
the monster even scarier.
All these techniques combine
into an assault on our senses.
They're part of the visual language
horror movies have developed
to make us doubt our own senses,
prepare for an attack,
and fully immerse ourselves in the scene
through the eyes of
both killer and victim.